vendredi 11 janvier dans les assiettes
des écoliers trappistes burritos dénoncé
de boeuf aux oignons la viande de type
chinoise
la ville travaille avec la ferme du
moulin situé à autant c'est la
différence entre la production qu'on
avait avant les salles là la production
qu'on avait avant on connaissait
l'alimentation des animaux mais on ne
savait pas d'où venait l'animal et
pourrait venir de l'autre bout de la
france ou même peut-être d'ailleurs
parce que c'était pas limité qu'avec à
la france un seul intermédiaire dans ce
circuit l'abattoir la viande limousine
est conditionnée sous vide dans les
prochaines semaines deux autres services
sont prévues dans les écoles et un au
self du personnel communal termes de
voix nous sommes sur 230 kg pour un
sauté de 110 kg pour un émincé et 160 kg
pour du rôti là-dessus s'ajoutent les 35
kg d'entrecôte que nous allons servir au
restaurant du personnel communal ce qui
représente à peu près la totalité des
trois bêtes que nous avons acheté leur
mac consulter au mois de juin en disant
qu'il avait des bêtes à vendre et que il
aimerait bien en faire profiter les
collectivités le projet est très
intéressant
près de 2000 personnes vont déguster
cette viande au mois de janvier le
produit représente une trentaine de
centimes par assiette la ville n'appuie
pas de changement de tarif